Donald Trump blurted out yesterday during
a brief Q&A after another one of these corona
virus propaganda events that he has been taking
hydroxy chloroquine for weeks now.
My immediate reaction, I don't know that he's
telling the truth.
And by the end of this story, I imagine many
of you will share these doubts.
What doctor would allow a president to take
something lacking any demonstrated benefit
with a high side-effect risk prophylactically,
particularly when Donald Trump is a borderline
or actually obese, which has negative interactions
with hydroxy chloroquine?
It sounds weird, but here is Trump saying
the context was attacking whistleblower Rick
Bright.
Here's Trump claiming to be taking hydroxy
chloroquine as he always inserts a sniff between
the two words.
But you people don't want to write the news,
you know.
But if you look.
But he's the one that signed the application.
The very important form he cited.
Now, if he doesn't believe in it, why would
he signed it?
And a lot of good things have come out about
the hydroxyl.
A lot of good things have come out.
And you'd be surprised that how many people
have taken it, especially the frontline workers,
before you catch it.
The frontline workers, many, many are taking
it.
I happened to be taking it.
Contracted jacket, hydroxide, torrico and
went right now?
Yeah.
Couple of weeks ago, I started taking it because
I think that's kind of hurt a lot of good
stories.
And if it's not good, I'll tell you right
dukkha to get hurt by it.
It's been around for 40 years for malaria,
for lupus, for other things.
I take it frontline workers take it.
A lot of doctors take it.
Excuse me.
A lot of doctors take it, I take it.
Now, I hope to not be able to take it soon
because, you know, I hope they come up with
some answer.
Do we believe White House doctors would let
Trump go on a medication?
Because he heard a lot of good stories.
So either Trump is taking it and it's crazy
since it has large side effect risks.
Trump is in his 70s with cardiovascular health
compromise or Trump is lying about it.
And that's also crazy.
Either way, this is crazy.
It's either stupidity or dishonesty.
Now, the backstory is that Hydroxy chloroquine,
among many others, is one possible treatment
for coronavirus that we looked at months ago.
I have no ideological opposition to it.
I listed it for you in a list of about seven
or eight drugs before Donald Trump ever mentioned
it.
I think it's fine to look into it.
So far, the good randomly controlled trials,
randomized controlled trials don't show that
it works.
Now, here's another interesting thing.
When you look into how hydroxy chloroquine
is dosed for malaria, which is what it's approved
for, it's one dose per week.
So you typically would start a week before
going to a country that has malaria risk.
You take one dose, then you take one dose
a week while you're there and then you continue
it for four weeks after you leave.
The wacky ideas from people like Sean HANNITY
and others is you take chloroquine daily.
So question one is, does Trump claim to be
taking one dose per week when he says, I've
been on it for two weeks?
Has Trump been taking it daily for two weeks,
which would really be wacky?
So then Trump says the White House doctor
signed off on him taking this.
Oh, I. I think for whatever it's worth, I
take it.
I was I. I would have told you that three,
four days ago.
But we never had a chance because you never
asked me the question.
The White House or the White House doctor
recommend that you take it out.
Is that why you're telling White House doctor
didn't recommend.
I asked him, what do you think?
You said, well, if you'd like it.
I said, yeah, I'd like it.
I'd like to take it.
A lot of people have taken a lot of frontline
workers who've taken Hydroxy Florrick with
a lot of frontdoor.
I don't take it because, hey, people said,
oh, maybe he owns a company.
No, I don't know the company.
You know what?
I want the people of this nation to feel good.
I don't want them being sick.
And there's a very good chance that this has
an impact.
So there he says, well, no, the White House
doctor didn't come to me about it.
I asked him and he said, it's OK for you to
take it.
Now, here's Jeff Mason from Reuters asking
what's the evidence that it actually.
Works prophylactically and listen to what
Donald Trump says.
Take it for about a week and a half now and
I'm still here.
Can you explain, sir, though, what is the
evidence that it has a preventative.
Here we go.
Are you ready?
Here's my evidence.
I get a lot of positive calls about it.
The only negative I've heard was the study
where they gave it.
Was it the V.A. with, you know, people that
aren't big.
Trump fans gave it.
And we've done the greatest job maybe of anything
in the V.A..
He gets calls about it.
So that's his evidence.
I like how he says.
The only evidence that it doesn't work is
that thing from the V.A.
That's the best randomized controlled trial
that we have.
That's the one that has a large sample size.
And Trump says other than that, which is,
by the way, the best test we have, the best
trial we have there, there's evidence that
it does work prophylactically now.
Shortly after Trump said this chaos completely
ensued and the White House doctor, Sean Connelly,
put out a memo about Trump and chloroquine.
And a whole bunch of people said, look, here's
the letter.
Here is the proof that Trump is taking Hydroxy
chloroquine.
Look at the letter.
It doesn't say Trump is taking it.
It's written in the most vague way possible.
And it doesn't say Trump is on the drug.
The letter that was published says two weeks
ago, a Trump staffer tested positive for the
virus.
The president is in good health.
Trump and the doctor had discussions about
hydroxy chloroquine and they concluded the
benefit outweighs the relative risk.
I continue to monitor studies.
The letter doesn't say we have put Donald
Trump on hydroxy chloroquine.
So I'm increasingly thinking this is something
Trump blurted out.
To get a reaction and it's not even true.
Although we may never know.
FDA has a warning, says avoid the use of hydroxy
chloroquine outside of a hospital or clinical
trial because of the potential increased risk
for serious heart related adverse events and
death.
So I don't actually care about Trump having
side effects at this point.
Listen, if Trump is going to insist on taking
something and ignoring the science he deserves,
whatever side effects he gets as a result.
The problem is that it puts others at risk
and encourages others to go and seek out prescriptions
for this medication.
It puts Trump in extra danger if he's telling
the truth.
Sure.
And Trump, by the way, has hypertension medication
he takes that increases the side effect risk
of hydroxy chloroquine.
But for me, the real signal that Trump is
lying is that the letter doesn't actually
say he's taking it.
And Trump says, I've been on it for a week
and a half or two.
If you're properly taking it, which is one
dose per week.
Trump saying I've been on it on a week and
a half or two.
Have you gotten one dose or two, one dose
or two?
Unless Trump is actually taking this daily,
which is absolutely bonkers, or it may all
be a lie.
We may never know.
But let's talk about some of the reactions
to Trump's claim.